now let me give you a slightly different
case okay
I said that this was a linear factor
down the bottom here okay the
denominator what happens if there's more
than one what happens if it makes the
degree of the bottom a bit higher for
instance let's do this
this is example1 example2 okay I'm gonna
keep that three X minus two now suppose
I have something a little bit
complicated
okay now without touching pens paper you
tell me why will this strategy over here
not work why will it fail when it comes
to this one down to one what's the
problem with it anyone confident to say
it in a particular way that I can hear
what what is the difference right degree
2 degree 1 ok if the degrees are the
same it's very easy to do this step here
right to get the numerator in terms of
the denominator but you try this with
this and you're in trouble you cannot
get something degree 1 in terms of
something in degree 2 without skipping
some square roots in there and it
turning out badly for you ok we'll get
to the square roots later so therefore
what are we gonna have to do here I'm
gonna teach you an important algebraic
trick really really cool it's cool and
maybe you want to put this off on the
side so we can revisit this question
it's called partial fractions okay now
just that I'm raise your hand if you've
seen this before yeah okay all right
let's give this a go
the idea of a partial fraction is to
take this and remember we said the
problem was this degree two down the
bottom okay if we had degree one we'd be
sweet but we can make a degree one take
this rational polynomial here
okay we can rewrite this in such a way
that you express it with those linear
factors that we're after which make
things all nice and neat okay because
when you think about it have a look at
this right hand side okay if you were to
add these up together what would you get
okay well you've got these different
factors here you have to get a common
denominator right that's how you add
fractions you would get this comment on
it but this is tons easier to work with
right so if I can get in this form
rather than this one I'll be sweet okay
by the way you all notice that is
congruence okay this is going to be true
for all values of X not just some of
them okay true and always true how do I
do it well I want you to notice that you
can treat this kind of like a quadratic
identity if I add these two together
okay and get that common denominator
what will I get what will the fraction
be you'll be a X minus 2 stuff to
multiply that and B X minus 1 right
that's my numerator and of course you
get the common denominator that you were
expecting
okay but if these are equal if these are
always equal and their denominators are
the same then the numerators must also
be the same
can you see that so I can take 3 X minus
2 will be equal to this
okay now remember what was I trying to
do I introduced this a and B these
numbers probably should have said yeah I
introduced them as numbers but I don't
know what they are okay you're used to
thinking of two variables right three
variables and one need two equations to
solve them right it looks like you've
only got one so what can I do here to
help me so it looks like there are three
variables right it's not really okay
these two closings here I can leave them
be X I can make whatever I like so long
as it's convenient to me okay maybe
anything alike so for instance you could
say let X equal 2 that would be a
convenient value Y it'll eliminate one
of the constants right which is the
whole problem okay in fact it eliminate
two because it gets rid of X and against
readon okay so let's do that right what
that leads to is what's the left-hand
side become it'll be 6 minus 2 which is
okay that's equivalent to actually
starting to what do we say this becomes
0 doesn't it I might as well write that
out so you see what's going on that's
the zero plus how many want to be am I
going to have 2 minus 1 which is just
the one isn't it okay so from this I see
these four okay and you can pull exactly
the same trick to get a then X equal one
that's gonna eliminate your be
chairman's give it a shortcut here 3
minus 2 is 1 that's going to be equal to
1 minus negative 1 is that ok
so now coming back if this is the case
I've got this up here negative one here
for there are you convinced so we just
test it out just to be sure because this
seems a bit especially this bit here
just like let's make it whatever number
one that's a bit hooker figures so just
to make sure it works okay let's add
them together shall we shall get -1 X
minus 2 for lots of X minus 1 all over
the common denominator which we've
already predefined what do you get off
the top negative x plus 2 for X minus 4
doesn't work you bet it does okay so
this technique is partial fractions
business it's deceptively simple isn't
it it's very simple yeah really
they say there's up to four units on
this well it's only when you meet these
kinds of problems that you need it
really ok so now let's have a go at this
problem I can rephrase it like so
negative 1 1 X minus
okay that's it and it's just too long
functions it oh yes I know what's this I
suppose I should do this